Carnegie Mellon has been home to
innovators like Randy Pausch and cool
projects like the GigaPan camera our
students professors and alumni have over
centuries worth of bragging rights find
out more at our website ww CMU edu /
brag click on any of the pictures to
learn some of Carnegie Mellon's biggest
ideas like this one here artificial
intelligence did you know that Carnegie
Mellon had the first computer that could
think definitely going to share that
with my tech savvy friends on Facebook I
can even personalize the message
and I can also share it on Twitter or
send an email to my mom who doesn't
social network yet Carnegie Mellon's
listed Big Ideas doesn't end here you
can brag about one of our other
innovations on the site to
visit w WC mu edu / brag to join the
conversation